hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the 2020 chasuble Masters
featuring a game that features more than
three moves
it's an England versus magnus carlsen
and this is Game six of their match
so the first for Game Center didn't draw
well not really in the draw
being disconnected in the first game
then Magnus sacrificed his Queen and
moved three and then the game three and
four were drawn and now Game five was
drawn Game five was a blitz game no
longer are they playing rapid and this
is now Game six of blitz so if this game
also ends in a draw we go to Armageddon
Game seven and if not we have the winner
of the of the first match so without
further ado let's check it out
ding with the white pieces opens with c4
as he did in the previous game that was
well so shortly abrupted and now Magnus
goes for e5 not e6 and Queen g5 like he
did in the previous game we have g3
night to have six and Bishop the g2
dings moves however are exactly the same
as in the previous game with Bishop to
c5 and now d3 yeah we have castles by
Magnus and the Knight to c3
now with h6 taking away the g5 Square
from the dark square Bishop and Knight
to f3 now just preparing the castle
Magnus goes rookie a to defenses pawn
and castles now and here there is one
game in the database where c6 was played
but here Magnus goes for d6 and it is as
of most seven that we have a completely
new game and now dink strikes in the
center he goes d4 now we have eight
captures and the Knight captures now
opening up the light square Bishop
diagonal so black needs to play c6
before the developing the light square
bishop as he does that we have c6 on the
board we have b3 and now a 5 just
further expanding on the Queen side
maybe ideas like 96 to c7 will be
possible in the future so here at Bishop
to b2 and here knife to a 6 by Magnus we
have Queen to d2 and developing the
Queen connecting rooks and the Queen to
e7 Magnus does the same we have rook a
to D 1 and now Bishop to d7
we have h3 making room for for King to
come to H 2 and in the future you want
to play a for F 4 and so on
so butter back the Beast
by Magnus and now II four and now if you
look at the position white is definitely
controlling more space he has a very
nice bind here on the central d5 square
his bishops are very powerful the dark
square bishop is very strong here also
the light square bishop and they're very
nicely placed and all in all white white
definitely is better here so nice to see
five by Magnus and now rook F 2 e 1 we
rook a to D H and now King to H 2 ding
just slowly keeps improving his position
and the best of the c8 by Magnus now
opening up the D file for the rook and
here the question is whether you want to
start further expanding with f4 and so
on
yeah or do you want to try something
else and the ding doesn't want to go for
it for he goes for Knight to f5 instead
which forces magnets to give up the
bishop pair and this is this is one of
those positions that you are better as a
white but you are better if nothing is
happening for example if you try some
some something active
I think scan very easily go wrong so
here now that mingoes Knight to f5 I'm
not saying that's what's gonna happen
here and so don't get the wrong idea and
now it's a it's a really strong night
it's a beautiful outpost for the night
attacks the Queen and Magnus decides to
eliminate it by giving up the bishop
pair so Bishop captures he captures and
now dink has a double deaf bond yeah
yeah a double deaf born so Queen back
the c7 and here we have rook captures an
e8 just trading rook so we have Knight
captures the rook needs to keep an eye
on the d6 pawn as does the Queen
so Knight captures any 8 and now Knight
back to e 2 opening up the dark square
Bishop diagonal and out the knight is
being driven over to f4 so Knight to d7
being also a magnet also wants to remain
over the knight to f6 with Knight to f4
and now Knight d2 f6 by Magnus and now
Queen to c2
you could try something like Bishop to
f3 to just keep an eye on everything and
you've moved to black but dingos Queen
to c2 and Queen to is a is a well a move
that is hard to explain
III think Geary mentioned that during
the the livestream as his match with
Knepper was over a bit
that he had no idea what Quinta situ was
and I also have no idea what Queen to c2
does other than it kind of guards the f7
point f5 point but other than that it is
it is very strange maybe yeah I have no
idea but okay we have Queen to e7 and
now comes Luke the d2 just adding more
protection to the second rank now the
the f2 point is nicely guarded twice we
have looked the d7 preparing Queen to d8
at some point black would really be
interested in pushing d5 so here at
Bishop to f3 just improving the position
we have Queen to d8 now again with
possibilities of maybe going d5 and the
Queen to d1 now just adding another
defender to the d5 square with Russia
back the c7 the bishop might be useful
on this diagonal and Knights the d3 now
trying to trick black into going d5
because if you go d5 now white can just
trade once and go Knights e5 and the
rook has nowhere to go I mean you could
go to e7 but then you lose the pawn or
if you go here just Knight character
some b7 wins so the magnets of course
doesn't go for that we have rook to e7
and here ding just goes back King to g2
we have Queen Tassie it by Magnus now
attacking the f5 pawn and the g4 Dean
just nicely defends it we have 9th to h7
now Dean has weakened some dark squares
here around his King may be nice to g5
will be an idea in the future and now
rook to eat you offering a trade of
rooks we have Queen to d8 defending the
rook and now rook captures we have Queen
captures and queen to e2
ding is controlling more more space here
and he would definitely enjoy trading
here
Queens here for example if captures
captures white is still controlling much
more space he he still has the better
bishop and he's still controlling d5
even though it looks like you can't push
d5 here and for your dark square bishop
it's not the case because after a trade
here captures captures ninety five wins
the pawn as after you defended with
let's say be 6 you get Knights to a4 and
now the bishop covers b5 you cannot push
the pawn and you're just gonna play
Bishop b4 and the window b6 pawn so it
loses the pawn by force
so Queen back to d8 Magnus of
the Queen trade and here we have King
2g1 we have night ETF six and now push
it back to g2 so a lot of maneuvering as
it is a blitz game so you don't have a
lot of time you just want to make good
moves without ruining your position as
it is a very complicated position so
tonight back to f80 I think sort of a
Magnus and Bishop to d4 now we have
night eight to d7 and Quinta III now and
here Bishop to b6 here Magnus finds a
way to trade some pieces I think says
okay we have bushel characters Queen
captures and here
Bing does go for the Queen trade but
here Magnus is more happy with his
position then then would a queen trade
as we've shown so characters captures
and now it's a bishop at night against
two nights so now let's see what happens
here we have f4 just two grabbing more
space here on the King side preparing
ideas like g5 so here you can again
consider the five but again if you go
default right away Knights the c5 will
be very annoying going after that b7
pawn and after a trade happens here you
will win this pawn and now there is no
way for you to defend it the c6 point so
it is uh well it's not something not
something you want to do so instead
night after b7 biding and the King to
have to do a sort of a Magnus and I
think now just brings the King into the
game King give to Magnus does the same
we have king to f8 and now g5 finally
when I starts pushing on the Kings side
with f6 by Magnus and h4 now we have
night to c5 Magnus offers a trade of
knights and even though you can double
across the pawns here it shouldn't be a
problem because the two pawns really
covered the lights were bishop nicely so
here ding just defense King III and the
Magnus traits here with characters
captures and the now King to e7 we have
King to d4 that's a very active king by
dink and now Knight to the a8 Magnus now
plants the theory maneuver denied so
bush of the e4 and Knights the c7 by
Magnus with a3 preparing to further push
would be four and the King to d7 now and
now we have B for a character say
characters captures and the now Magnus
the position with b5 so it seems like
for the entire game it's Bing who's
pushing and Magnus is just trying to
defend a bit more passive position and
now here you have to be very careful
what you play here best for best for
white would be something like Bishop to
d3 or or even to just capture on b5 the
problem with capturing on b5 is that now
the knight can capture and now you have
these two points which are which are
very strong and White has the isolated
beep on which could become a target
later on as it is on a dark square so
dink said okay I'm not gonna capture or
Bishop d3 I'm gonna play something even
better I'm gonna play c5 now you either
capture and allow me to recapture or you
can push just let something like e5 but
then it's not not gonna be not gonna be
a problem for me I'm just gonna move my
Bishop and that's it your knight will
not have any ways of entering the game
however this move by ding loses the game
so feel free to pause the video and
solve this end game for Magnus while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those who were able to do it
congratulations on being an excellent
endgame player and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's night a six
and night to a six is a really really
strong move as it welcomes with the
threat of winning upon so ding says okay
I'm gonna trade on d6 with chapters
captors and King c3 so everything is
defended now the knife cannot capture
but now comes c5 and again there's the
threat of just Knight captures and b4
and then the two passports will be of
course completely winning
so Dean captures and c5 but now King
characters and Magnus got his King all
the way from the seventh rank now to c5
and he's threatening b4 and so on
so here at Bishop - see - the bishop is
ready to to guard against any any tricks
here
however this Bishop to see to move just
makes it a whole lot easier for Magnus
to end the game he goes night before and
now the problem is even though the
material on the board is equal you
cannot allow this trade because then the
White King will need to tend the to the
pawn here well the black King will just
gobble up all of these pawns and win the
game easily so you cannot afford the
Queen
so here dingos Queen to Bishop to b3 but
now Magnus just plays Knight to d5 check
and it was in this position unmoved 55
that the England resigned the game so
Magnus wins Game six and also the first
match so yes the the good deed goes
unpunished and yeah here we resigned
because it's checked and you're gonna
lose the pawn so like we said you cannot
avoid a trade if you capture character
then you're just gonna have to deal with
the past pawn while the black King
gobbles up for all of these points or if
even if why trades once you're is still
gonna gobble up these guys and just
start pushing your past pawns or if you
go for something else for example after
this 95 checked you to play King d3
captures with check King III you're
gonna move the knight back let's say
with check King e4 but now after the
knight moves it's still completely
winning now you're even up upon which is
much better and there's not much to look
for here you could trade maybe
characters captures but still with the
black King being so it was so active it
will be very easy to push the pawn and
just win the game outright and it does
help black a lot that or all of his
pawns on the King side are in dark
squares so the light square bishop is
useless in this case so after Knight to
d5 check ding resigns and Magnus takes
match 1 ah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Victor
Gannon Phillip Eastlake Peter Rasmussen
Kevin Johnson and Stefan Lynn pointer
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chests
full masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chests world and yes we
are going to have at our game tomorrow
to celebrate the 700,000 subscribers
milestone what I didn't want to make
this video about that we're gonna make
in the next video about that and
celebrate it properly so I think oh I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day